you ready yeah citizens of the reject
Nation I finally have a real reex
t-shirt on and I think he might my name
is Terra by the way it says RR reject of
course it's a real reject t-shirt I'm
not going to lie I wasn't 100% sure
about red and white for that tea the
services one you the guinea pig for it
and I think it looks great I bought it
and it's fantastic I think it looks
great it's worth every penny spent
listen we're going to watch pixels we've
both had a rough day so we're choosing
comedy you got to get on it you got to
make sure you leave a like you type in
there into the into the dupes a comment
you got to leave a comment but you also
got to ring the
bell ring the bell and subscribe patrons
patrons you're not already Patron we
call you super sexy over there you can
get down with it get sexy get on the
patreon you can watch exclusive content
and highlights especially with Greg and
John over there they have a bunch of
stuff but then you can also do like a
full syn up with the full copy with us
and watch the whole pixels with us
together if you get on patreon okay I
think that's it like what else do I have
to say I don't know Matt's part of
hosting a YouTube a thriving YouTube
channel is you say way more things that
the audience wants to
hear never heard of them
before yeah rocking and rolling
already familiar music that's a big part
of Adam seller movies welcome to the80s
it is summer 82 yes called it open come
on hey give me back
my I assume every child is Adam
Sandler's
children
surrender Chris Columbus made this movie
okay what else has he made don't ask I
was worried once I once you said it I
was like I can't recall any movies great
I think you made Home
Alone Peter dink just this shut up how
are you so good at this you've never
even played it before
[Music]
Destiny do they still have arcade
championships oh good question I don't
know you're l l lamon soft who told you
that the government cuz I'm this close
to figuring out the secret of the
Bermuda Triangle oh my God I love this
kid this movie just got
great oh
waa my hands are blazing fast and also I
will blast and burn all my competitor's
weak ass
mood I can't wait for little people
jokes welcome gamer Dan first annual
worldwide I really like that their style
to the credits oh yeah it looks like a
video game with the hope of connecting
to and perhaps providing a message for
extraterrestrial life oh space based on
a short film oh that's really cool
that's a like a dream come true to have
a adaptation brought to
life that is not Peter Dinklage no it's
not not all little people are the same
yeah I was like but then why why are we
I think it's a young Peter Dinklage
actually okay yeah that's what I
was I think it is him but the age or
something but it's the got it either
we're both terrible people or we got
well gentlemen how about we break this
tie let's play Donkey Kong
hoot hoot hoot hoot visuals are
surprisingly well done yeah I love the
editing of that that's cool yeah
surprisingly cool little Scott Pilgrim
Vibes I love movies that edit with music
hell yeah congratulations on coming in
second you prick is he going to cry
Blaster is the World Champ What are you
how dare you is that boy going to cry
after losing in public in front of all
these people the thing he was really
passionate about you're still going to
go to MIT and something that makes you a
millionaire and maybe even marry Olivia
Newton John like it's just it's Donkey
Kong man we don't got to cry bu yeah we
do a plus you're married to a woman who
hates you she doesn't hate me she just
doesn't get it you know oh man I don't
have the free time to do stuff together
like we did 10 years ago he always has
Kevin James and shitty relationships in
his
movies catastrophic catastrophic I got
it sweetheart okay damn great coverage
on these yell at me you're
mean the casting for the kids is 10 out
of
10 you got to learn how to read buddy
it's as simple as
that I was on three hours sleep all
right nice to see is he the actual
president yeah I guess so that's why
it's all thrown out cuz he's the actual
president mean you incredible at video
games back in the day but that's a
useless skill now it's like being a
great blacksmith I love that the
president has time to talk to yeah Mr
President if you take away all the
library sir how will the children ever
learn to
read that's a terrible friend right
there oh this is like the video game
what's you call it t no no no
the gala I forget I forget the names of
all I know what you're talking about
yeah I always play it too this that
transition was dope hello I am a nerd
from the nerd Brigade here to nerd out
on all your audio and visual needs do
you have to say that every time you show
up at a house if I want to get paid yes
isn't that kind of demeaning only if
someone brings it
up thanks oh so it's like 10 birthdays
yeah my dad cheated on my mom with his
19-year-old Pates
instructor
when your son told me that your husband
left you for 19y old I guess I thought
of you were going to be like one of
those hot when we first met in high
school oh just have a fling with him
yeah do it Lady Michelle
Michelle what's her name Michelle
Monahan yeah okay I did have it right
but then I was like I might be
wrong
what the hell are those oh this is going
to be like they're fighting but fighting
against a video game but in real life I
love it I played when I was your age
were you any good just a reminder Tara
did not ever see the trailer for this so
she has no idea I don't I'm probably
saying a lot of things that you guys are
like we already knew that no no it's
great not judging but what are you doing
in the closet maybe she's changing I'm
mostly
crying yeah a little drinking a little
drinking probably equally crying and
drinking something I do often also are
you all right I'm sobbing on the floor
my closet drinking charlot out of his
sippy cup so I guess not that shot with
the mirror is a surprisingly good
shot yeah that is that's
[Laughter]
awesome want to talk about it no this is
good this is when you take advantage of
her in her vulnerable state that's how
you do it guys out of
here
wowza wow Whoa man if only these army
people knew about video games it's nice
to see a comedy shot with a sense of
style yeah whoa this is that's cool I
love just what happened just what
happened just what just happened just
what happened I love
[Laughter]
it oh oh my God get out of out of there
get out of there cubed cool I mean this
point I'd be like just take
me take me to
Pacman or Mrs Mrs Pac it's not even
spelled
correctly also it will end terribly for
him she's 19 but she's probably hot I
know but she knows nothing but when
you're having a midlife crisis that's
what counts what's going to happen when
she wanders into a bar and she sees a
normal 25-year-old man and she's like
didn't help us you already married the
wrong guy you got the worst part over
with true divorce is Good married the
wrong girl divorce is great maybe it
just means we're going to meet the right
person now this is their meat cute in
the closet with
wine uhoh oh no no to no are you trying
to kiss me absolutely not
oh offense I don't think my rebound guy
is a 210 lb person that installs flat
screens for a living no offense that's
very offensive uh rude I am not a snob
that's pretty snoby s i was a
billionaire and we were out on my giant
yacht in the middle of the Mediterranean
sipping champagne and I went in to kiss
you would you have kissed me back then
yeah I would have kissed the guy yeah me
too give me more of that champagne when
can I come on this yacht again for the
record I'm an amazing kisser all us
nerds are cuz we appreciate it more Amen
brother you didn't even brush your teeth
this morning I hate a Tic
Tac I will say compared to other Adam
Sandler comedies as of late this one's
great I really love it and I like that
there's a different kind of dynamic with
the love interest versus they just get
along he got to the White House in 15
minutes that's insane reminds me of the
show 24 when they were like yeah I'll
make it to LAX in 10 minutes I'm like
those are all lies we right on through
Lieutenant
Colonel Lieutenant Colonel yeah what
they just keep subverting expectations
on the female leading stereotype Colonel
Ben Patton you can go right into the
Situation Room Mr berer the president is
waiting for you in the Oval Office
somebody's more
important Freddy can you keep the Riff
Raff out of here like how they had to
cut in on that because it obviously
wasn't Adam Sandler actually doing it
does that sound familiar to you yeah
where do I know that from you freeze it
yeah hold
on this movie is like every slacker
nerds
fantasy hanging out with the president
you take your gaming skills to saving
the
world I love it preliminary indications
are that we were attacked by G Galaga oh
yeah Galaga that's what it's called G
gag sons of
[__] then let's blow Gallagher to
Hell who's
Gallagher this is the 1982 arcade
version kind of Ziggy zaggy Ziggy zaggy
is that the snobby
term design these space bugs after an
old out of print version of a video game
does she really get to talk twice she's
not even at the grown-ups table yeah and
she's a
woman get this girl out of here if this
gets out to the press that we're pinning
the blame on some old computer game
impu you'll be fine we've seen it your
impeach end
okay know is that a naked butt in the
background it might be oh it is
oh it wasn't naked it was just
khakis just jeans I was like
what stop it's me it's me it's l it's l
oh at the beginning of the movie CIA has
been tapping my phones ever since I
found out this auder film has been
edited JFK shot first llo it is
you you're the first guest I've had here
Walt Disney that's a shocker wow I think
they really lean into their like
sci-fi uh tones in a really fun
Whimsical way actually I think if she
was real things might just play out a
little bit differently you want to know
how I know that in the game if she was
real a book written and illustrated by L
soft oh boy oh my God I love it she
just why am I here right now why did you
try to rofy me right thank you for
reminding me uhhuh
okay do you remember how there was a
tape of the event in all the games that
were played that was then put in a
capsule and shot out into the universe
looking for extraterrestrial life oh I
get it and has sent down real life
versions of of what they saw to attack
us they probably thought that's what
Humanity was or what weapons
are we are aace from the planet vula we
came to you in these familiar Earth
forms to tell you we received your
vessel this all happened on National
Television you have two lives left
losing both will lead to the total
Destruction of your planet did they
actually get Don to is that some old
archive footage we don't know about at
least warn the people of India something
could be coming the whole country thinks
I'm a buffoon right now as it is I can't
risk it brener I just can't and this is
how they sold movie pixels in
India
whoa he's going
live I think he's just recording he's
going
recording that the most relatable
thing try
record going to try recording I would
have tried that is a disturbing effect
actually we Now understand the entities
that attacked this were made of energy
intelligent energy morning Colonel good
morning
Michael what cool head Mel the cubes we
recovered in Guam are normally pretty
feisty oh he didn't like it
though I love how Adam Sandler's
attitude is always just so passive and
unaffected
and the uh uh slut-seeking missile I'd
love to see that do you have that around
here that's great that's a great call
back I so regret trying to kiss you I
would kiss the guy in the yacht a 100
times before I kissed you of course snob
oh it hurt his feelings civilian
arcaders who we are required to listen
to for 120 seconds starting I can't do
this I love ran know now I can't do this
I love no matter what genre Brian Cox is
in he is so committed perfect someone
forgot to send us the best of the best
oops and instead dropped off a bunch of
incontinent adult diaper
wearing women baby men people what am I
looking at right now are you guys
soldiers or the cast a magic mic what
are you doing you do you feel me s You
Beautiful Nubian man you gorgeous
specimen of what God can
make form extremely complex Mo defeats
with hand eye coordination unique to a
very specific cognitive Acuity I learned
a lot of big words at the dorm room drug
parties let us teach you a few things in
the little time we have we might help
you win this thing I love how they're
the two most qualified people like
yeah ain't no way Ink's catching up to
you I want you to focus mostly on the
ships no distractions just us oh my God
his wife who whoa Big W from 30 Rock
yeah Jane k Kowski the next battle is on
at sundown tomorrow 5130 29 latitude
0942 longitude where is that London in
London England everybody believes
currently that I'm from there oh dude
you're nailing the near by there would
you like small T I know how to do
cookney pretty well London is more
proper
proper it's a lot more
[Applause]
proper that's great oh my God see it was
a naked butt in the beginning we he's
got he's got
he's going to die Shan Bean dies I don't
want to hear another word out of you
walk in weer coat what wiener coat it's
really is just like one of those big a
coat for your wieners yeah okay you said
it was a big okay I get what you were
trying to say I was trying to make a
different point okay about how it's like
a big sci-fi movie of Alien Invasion W
came got it I know right but yeah sure
big wiener I just want to touch
it easy with those light cannons that's
a cool shot boom boom boom there's some
surprisingly good shots at this comedy
movie yeah just remember who you're
talking to Missy move it colonel don't
worry they're going to work he was kind
that was sweet in case it's Space
Invaders I just thought of something I
should tell please return to the support
area we know where to find you all right
now booger off but he's the guy you
need I love all these like quick moving
crane shots it's great it's so pretty
though oh snap
wa it's centipede what a great
advertisement exactly what we talked
about right people are like what's
centipede got to go find it now I don't
know centipede centipede is a oh you
know Cen yeah know I oh wow that's why I
brought you here cuz I forgot the how
old you are yeah I'm
55 my God will you please find the
pattern and anticipate I don't know the
pattern Sergeant death
12:00 oh wa Dam oh bye-bye kind scary oh
no [__] just got
real the hell kind of be commercial
is there's really great callbacks in
thisal grab the done yourself dude yeah
buddy there we go oh my God this the
most badass he's ever looked [__]
y he's saving the world whoa this movie
is making Adam Sandler look like an
action
[Music]
hero something he will never
be this is such a nerd fantasy I am
eating this up you mess with the wrong
planet from Len to Jon gr what the hell
are you saying I
know me no look at me I look delicious
they'll gobble me up like space dim some
oh I can't wait for the president to get
involved come on you're the Wonder kid
you've no authority to dispense weapons
here Mr brener oh my God Mr President
let let the Nerds take over what was
that sir let the Nerds take over let the
Nerds take over
I want that on a t-shirt let the Nerds
take
over I would wear it every
day yeah baby it's actually a cool
concept to take these arcade games to
turn them into like
[Music]
villains that's really
dangerous there's people back
there what would you do after this is
all solved though reconsider a lot of
things we
can actually I feel like you would just
get really good at video games you know
a movie is working when you don't even
know what the game is yeah it's like a
basic concept to understand though yeah
these effects are really good they're
surprising that looks awesome 30 years
since I kicked your butt like there's
effects from movies right now that I'm
like they don't look good and this looks
dope wow wa arms yes let's take it for
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's so dumb and
cute how does she not hear this she's
old Gregory
[Applause]
perfect shot
nice who are you mis son I'm just a
loser who's good at old video games well
thank God for that bring down the US
government you know you're all right
priner you're all right too snobby
you're going to nurse that all night
long or when are you going to start
snobby hottie that's what I'd call her
she's really hot m I was the Vodka shot
record holder in my class at West Point
that's not vodka that's a skull that's
tequila please accept one of our
Warriors as a trophy of your Victory I'm
pretty sure they're just taking this old
footage and they're doing lip dubbing
that is so cool they're doing duck
[Music]
hunt the details will be sent via this
signal shortly there just some digital
effects real leading two battles to one
I think you might be right about the lip
dubbing be it buddy there's nobody
better than you
well not at every game o Peter Dinklage
Peter Dage where is he know he's R
Runner come on now we don't even know
where to find that
idiot yes I can't wait made about 50
million before he was convicted in
sentenced to 20 years in
prison he just such an ultimate badass
oh God I love him get me out of here
it's that mean centipede killer I hope
you don't at me with his space gun sup
second place oh in your Sidekick here
this is why I don't think I can have
Brena on my team he's just not really a
gamer did he have a southern draw at the
beginning of the movie
yeah no no no hey he hey here come on
sit down okay this like d personally
speak to the parole board and I want a
stealth attack helicopter like they fly
over the Super Bowl at my disp at all
times you so I can fly around if you
help us beat these things I think we can
get you out of here and the Martha
Serena
sandwich pick one of them we'll set up a
coffee Serena Williams and we are
[Music]
closed hello he made the right call
Serena's the better understand but
Martha Stewart knows how to decorate New
York City oh forget about it
it's nice to see him let
loose solid establishing shot damn it
got a lot of big uh Big Crane shots in
this rookie just tell him what you saw
it was it was awful nice like one of
those monster movies you know but this
time the monster was real and who was
this monster Pac-Man yes Pacman boom
that's my jam boom let's get us some
little ghosts you want ghosts she's got
ghosts ghosts oh man dude I totally get
how they were able to fun this movie
awesome cuz it's so awesome so much
they're going to go that's so cool four
many generators for each of the cars
ghost we're calling them
xm950 love how they had this prepared in
case that they had Pac-Man why are there
four of them there's only three of us
who's our fourth may I introduce to you
professor toru iwatani is that the
inventor ofac creator of Pac-Man oh
[Laughter]
man you speak Japanese no sir what an
honor thanks for all the joy you brought
to our lives even in an accent I made
your game my [__] what is a b a
mhm Buckle them in you all right yeah
why L's right you do smell good good
luck yeah don't buckle in any of the
other guys that way I know you really
like me for me all he had to do is
become a big Action Hero gentlemen I'll
be sending Pac-Man's current coordinates
to each of your cars GPS's let's locate
and eliminate is this about to turn into
the Fast and the Furious or The Italian
Job have you seen that oh yeah that's
such a great
[Applause]
movie
that is
awesome Pac-Man's a bad
guy uh-oh oh I created him to bring joy
to all the people of the world I
brainwashed
him oh my God I love it it's kind
gentle it's one you can tell your
troubles to or grab a hamburger with
what is that your Pac-Man it is his
Pac-Man this just some like you'll see
Recreation you'll see I knew it I was
like I hope he gets out of the car and
talks to it and it's like you're not
you're not meant for this I would talk
to him yes he's my son no that's a bad
idea it's a great idea I love everything
about it he just listening
hello my sweet little boy he's going to
die right like immediately think you
grown I know you're a good
boy he's going to be
chomped
[Music]
oh somebody kill the stupid
be all right losers three on one let's
hit it oh they got rid of the inventor
wonder if there was the actual
inventor he is right I assume he is
yeah whoa that was a cool
shot yeah they have a great way of like
because it's part of the world that
whatever it comes in contact with turns
into a cube it makes it look more
tangible and real
yeah they couldn't have made their cars
faster they're just Mini Coopers they're
not that fast Mini Coopers are known to
be so
[Music]
fast Neato whoa Eddie how did you do
that so fast cuz I'm the champ
lieutenant do it off screen I mean if it
was me I'd be in like a 1967 elor a
Mustang or a Camaro wen't you guys
ghosting
it
oh way' it Go Peter but doesn't it
usually have three lives yeah they got
to do it two more
times I love Pac-Man all right Pac-Man
number two just regenerated four streets
away headed Northbound I would love to
get a Pac-Man AR yeah that'd be cool I
would love to not pay you to be here and
use all that
[Laughter]
[Music]
money what you guys forgot to anticipate
he's coming for you know what he hate
the power pellet Pac-Man's got 10
seconds where he can eat us oh God I
didn't know it was only 10 seconds is
whole my whole life I did not know that
only 10 seconds you just got to survive
oh which obviously you never did oh God
don't eat me don't eat me don't eat me
please please don't eat me oh gosh
no oh that's going to be awesome if they
show him just in a cut off car the rest
of the time I'm going to
die
oh who all right one up let run PP your
legs go baby someone's going to run into
him right now
yay how the hell did he get over there
so
fast way to go champ there's a dve
Busters in the backr yeah thrilled one
more to go in a happy
hour I love that that was probably
intentional oh no what oh no BR it's on
you Peter can swim there are still three
other power pellets out there so stay
alert yo this is more than just a video
game you are driving on the streets of
New York
City I feel like you could have gotten
an actual professional driver instead of
Gamers for this yeah true
six that is some serious backward
driving
[Music]
eight
n
whoa it's going to bump into him 10
perfectly
timed wow you are the most badass guy in
the world wait a minute he was Zohan he
can do action he actually did like
Israeli military training for that movie
he did yeah he actually knows how to
[Applause]
yeah I don't know why that just popped
in my head right now
brvo yes then he's also a
Superstar nerd
Fantom government will chew you up and
spit you out though after this let me
guess Michelle comes down and she's like
I don't know I'm thinking about the line
that she's going to say we love you Mr
President thank you for saving
us I don't know what would be worse them
failing are them actually pulling this
off this movie about to take a
completely unnecessary turn I yes
so do you recognize this game for my
life do you know what this game is is
this left for dead no oh that's the only
video game I know and I loved it it's
The Last of
Us come on
up I feel bad because I was going to
wear a real reject Last of Us shirt
today but you got one on no I don't one
of our two he's so
cute oh no sorry oh good again I'm a
snob I have mental problems I'm willing
to overlook that for the
evening I like their chemist I I
normally feel like Adam Sandler wies in
movies like there's no chemistry they
just cast like hot woman you're my
likable wife agree and she's they
actually have like a build in their
development of their relationship it's
like cute pass it's cute
yeah look at him oh my God he's he's
he's back from Hitch he just has to be
himself well look at here Serena they
threw me a big party to thank oh my God
they got Serena he actually got Serena
they promised me an island if I did
[Laughter]
this wower dang girl excuse me for a
second like that's his new future family
dance I like how everyone's accepting
this alien creature and not going like
it's shouldn't we fear this yeah like
it's just it is what happened brush your
teeth you brushed your teeth yes yes
callbacks in this are 10 out of 10
man he's musically trained you know who
he is Olaf right yep does he sing a lot
in that movie I'm not Olaf sings A lotf
has a whole musical number even think
about touching me I'm going to smack you
through the wall I'd have it no other
way should have gone with Martha Stewart
then I'd have a tasty Panini cooked for
me or
something you have violated the rules of
warfare dudes violated the rules because
of this you forfeit and your planet is
now ours oh Peter Dinklage cheated what
that's why he was going so fast oh what
the heck are they talking about me that
song yeah oh oh you're in trouble now
the Pac-Man cheat code for super speed
you're a cheater so what I used cheat
codes back in the day to help me
dominate he's not a real master that's
how I beat your boy brener at the world
championship oh yeah oh you son of a
[__] oh man I have everything I have to
these bitching shads this ends
now how could it apply to a car though
drop dead Admiral you're done all right
hey guys it's enough
listen we tried something it didn't work
what do you think it's going to be you
going to be doggy Kong I really don't
know what about duck hunt oh we just saw
the dog no no now it's personal oh boy
uh-oh this is no good where's Eddie
Eddie yeah crawled into a hole we'll
never see him again oh and the little
boy is the only one with the
answers wait a second cubert is from
there he knows all their secrets yeah
ask him all the questions we have a
positive can do
attitude I'm kidding we are all going to
die I'm just
[Music]
sorry oh my God Ready Player One waa
have you seen Ready Player one yeah
great
film damn you Terra could have reacted
to
iter whoa
wow they're not even naming them now for
me to remember what the names are just a
lot of familiar
[Music]
imagery
Tetris wa that's a clever way to make
tet antagonistic
yeah who is it
nobody's better at the oh [__] the
president's here thanks for being my
friend of course buddy I love you I go
kick some
ass you know everyone says Adam Sandler
is like the nicest guy everyone says
that yeah like real life I bet you he
is some
murfs so
hot what is this game I don't know what
that game is get away from those kids
now uh please paper boy in the
background nice head shot oh my God
she's real the girl of his dreams damn
she does look hot hey girl hey is
that ashle something one of those hot
actresses that's her she's an actress
and she's hot I prayed for
this but apparently you don't feel the
same no dude winner over you're in luck
the boss wants to meet you in person who
is this I don't know I've been trying
you save your planet and destroy our
Warriors put in the coms but if you
lose uhhuh looks like one of those
creepy '90s sci-fi things at least I can
die a happy man knowing that I found
true
love recognize
him she's like so subtle in her reaction
to it
all
wow Josh
you lucky guy and I couldn't even get a
handshake from Serena Williams I had to
prove to myself do this without cheating
wait you cheated moving
[Laughter]
on
perfect
love I like this movie way more than I
thought I would yeah it's great it's a
lot of
fun what is that
noise it is is Donkey
Kong I was going to say oh that's really
neat they set him up for so long that I
was like it would be a real
disappointment if they didn't use it
that's awesome the one game you suck at
yeah oh they got a rescue hit oh that's
clever cool oh no oh
no
a God I can't pinpoint that robot game
it's really bugging me
Just Let It Go Greg Let It Go many of
them I mean what's that chef from I
don't know what a lot of these are
[Music]
from W awesome this is a really cool
looking set yeah looks like they
actually built something and mixed it
with visual effect actually yeah
yeah damn that was cool oh
you damn I can't do this there's no
pattern pretend you're the guy and you
don't want to die yeah man I couldn't
even beat any plant any plant's a
cheater that's why he was so good in New
York he used cheat codes he can see it
now you know what that means right
you're the
best I'm the Donkey Kong champion of the
world Donkey Kong champion of the world
doesn't need
patterns button I found that really
funny oh love commitment to it sincerity
of oh my God that was the most genuine
delivery of that line that was so
awesome rock
you
please oh help him what no
no
dope this a
remix yeah yeah yeah took me a second to
pick up on
it this shouldn't be so cool but it is
it's so it's so
cool
yeah damn you just needed the
confidence oh this would have been so
cool to be born yet when this movie came
out to go to the popup bar I've been
waiting to do this since
[Music]
yeah
wa other than the one Frogger thing
Kevin James really hasn't done much in
this movie but no in terms of like
fighting the AL yeah he was just kind of
there my second favorite President you
know Obama's still my man right oh okay
so he this is a fictional movie if Trump
did beo president get
ches no more
taxes we did it
baby we did it oh
[Music]
right I love Peter dig reaction to that
he's just like waa
man Brena you are the best in the
world the Donkey
Kong lady Lisa she made an appearance
and while you guys were out you know
saving the world you kind of destroyed
his oh that's horrible Jen she's so
underused though oh yeah she literally
has had two lines I guess we get to keep
the trophies yeah but he had a trophy
wife can he morph into her which would
have its own weird
implications yeah I feel like what's
happening it might happen that mean
they're going to lose cubert though he
loses his friend so she gets get the
[Applause]
[Music]
wife what about cu no one else is
weirded out by this that was just
cubert thank
you I have broken a peace treaty with
the Alien
Invaders I think Chris Columbus directed
one of the Harry Potter movies really
yeah I think so nerds are the greatest
kissers prove it I'll be the judge of
that for want get a round of applause
yay is it is it Martha Stewart is it did
they get Martha oh
Serena it's a pleasant surprise oh my
God
got that's so funny that's a really
funny ending are they just now leaving
ah he's
[Music]
back game over yeah my shirt literally
or shirt literally says game over game
over one year later what's going on here
did she pop out of baby for for
him oh okay
yeah oh
God what is a funny ass
ending that's great wow I like the music
in this film I actually always like the
music in Adam Sanders films cuz I'm 65
years old this was a fun movie it was
fun these are some really inventive
credits yes I love it also if you guys
are listening to this remember on
Spotify or on Apple podcast or any
podcast make sure that you rate this
episode please we love it and you now
let's get into the review I just rhymed
you did just rhy I felt it you felt it
everybody felt it yeah it was very very
impressive thank you now before we go
into this review I did want to say Tera
just another compliment what is it
what's it going to be those people on
Apple and Spotify I probably can't I
don't know I think there's a video on
there it's been a while since I've I put
someone else in charge of it PL I hope
you're doing a good job on there is it
audio or
video so are there are video now I'm not
sure actually ah but that shirt looks
great on you terara I'm transitioning
everyone here at the on the channel now
has shirts I appreciate everyone who
bought one
buying that one and uh to everyone in
reject Nation who has bought a shirt
thank you so much I got this r on right
now the game over shirt here it is on
screen for y'all I love that one every
shirt that you see from the reject
Nation shop we have personally been
involved with with helping to uh create
ourselves then you know we also got like
our space babies of the galaxy shirt
which is another one of our favores I
got this America's ass one which is a
homelander but we got a whole bunch of
other te's seriously thank you guys it's
personally my favorite way for people
that support the channel just because I
think this is the first one you're
wearing can you attest that it actually
feels we made sure that the fabric that
we got is actually nice shirt that I I
want to wear and even if I wash it it's
still going to be it's going to be even
more soft and cuddly because I have a
billion shirts that I do not wear
because I hate they're hard material
they're gross like these are not that
they're very comfy really care about the
fabric and uh so yeah guys thank you so
much but Tera please oh you want me to
tell you what I thought about the film I
want you to talk about it darling yeah
all right and I really liked it a lot I
thought it was a lot of fun I'm uh I
like number one for me in the script all
of the callbacks like if I were if I was
reading this script I would go the
callbacks in this make this movie just
like take it from like an eight to a 10
the callbacks are hilarious and they're
really the the pacing of this especially
comedic wise of course with the actors
because they're comedic actors but
specifically with the editing that does
matter and all of the pacing of the
editing was really spoton when it came
to the comedy delivery which I really
really liked um and just an real a very
inventive and fun story like watching
video games and having to fight him is
rad um and I you know like what you were
saying about uh Adam Sandler and like
his wives and like sometimes Adam
Sandler films they come off to me like
from the beginning I already know that I
might be like taken out of it or that
it'll be too corny and this one I was
like sold on it immediately like from
the start
also my last thing and then I'm all let
Greg take it away the kid in the
beginning who plays he played uh Josh
Gat
character where did that kid go cuz
someone needs to cast him in everything
he's hilarious like I want that kid to
be in my short films that's all I got to
say no dude I'm sure you got more to say
I love what you have to say I have a lot
but I also I already talked about the
music solid I I think this
movie gets so many points from me I'm I
am by no means an Adam Sandler I love
Adam Sandler and I know that when it
comes to you know review circles
especially he is very much consistently
critically panned for a lot other than
his dramas which he's a fantastic
dramatic actor yeah cuz it is strange he
demonstrates so much of his
versatility and and uh so much of his
depth in his dramatic roles yeah and
then he does comedies and usually he's
just like hanging out on camera like
most of the time sometimes he puts a
little bit more effort than usual but
most even this is a great example like
yeah he kind of just hangs out he just
hangs out on camera and and and to me I
can still see those Sometimes they come
across like a lazy film they can come
across like he's just on vacation and
they got cameras pointed but sometimes
that's still enjoyable you know yeah uh
what I so this gets a lot more points
for me because I know so many of those
other films uh and this you could really
feel the conscientious effort I feel put
in you know so already on that
comparative note it gets a lot more
points because I think directing wise
there's a lot of great effort here
there's a lot of cool like symmetry with
the shots the visual effects uh the
world of them is really neat and then on
just a standalone as a comedy movie you
know I really don't feel like we get as
many comedy films now we don't you know
it's kind of like a dying film genre
yeah it kind of is and then whenever
they come out in the theaters they tend
to flop you don't you don't get just
direct like theatrical comedies anymore
yeah weird I'm now just it's hitting my
brain where I I'm I'm thinking like more
recently it's been like right it went
like Barbie Oppenheimer and then we get
like well now it would be Expendables
and these are movies I you are John Wick
Expendables and uh what's the one with
uh I need to watch it equalizer
equalizer those are I'm naming movies
that are not comedies I don't know I
can't name a comedy that has come out is
it like a Dying Breed now there was Joy
Ride and no hard feelings I saw no hard
feelings so yes they do still exist they
exist but they don't like it's it's uh
it's doing well on Netflix but they
don't do well in the theaters anymore in
the theaters anymore it's been a long
time yeah I mean the last time I feel
like I watched a like a comedic film is
on Netflix would be like oh you click it
at home right you're not going to pay
exactly they're usually like streaming
and a lot of times they have to be a
little bit more High concept like
something a little bit more akin to this
where it's like like it's like action
sci-fi adjacent to the comedy right so
yeah I mean it goes down that path but I
the reason I'm saying saying that is
that I was like it's it was just nice to
watch a comedy again and it was my the
little nitpicks are yeah Jan Kowski or
whatever her name is
krinski sure yeah that's John that's
John I don't know what her name is yes I
do Kowski monik is lazowski I think
she's Kowski I love him okay then
there's John krinski yeah then he did um
quiet place yes and he was in some other
comedy show and they think I don't know
but but you know something
than more than you let on I get what you
do you play the you you weaponize your
incompetence I do that in my
relationship you do it on camera I do it
on camera for the people for the public
for all the world to see so but the this
other than like okay yeah any comedy
movie is going to have jokes that are
not that funny that it's just how the
territory goes like you're going to not
and sometimes some my find every joke
funny sometimes not funny yeah then and
then Jane Kowski was um disappoint like
yeah like why C two lines she's known
for not cast her and you're paying her a
daily rate every time she is there on
set acting and if they take a percentage
and that's how they got these people
like they're only on there for a second
when I saw Michelle Monahan's name I
thought she would be utilized the way
Jane k yeah but when I saw Jane kosowski
I was like oh comedic actress this is
probably going to be worthwhile and they
did nothing like she's there's not even
anything remotely attempting to be F
playing a wife she's yeah remarkably
straightforward count them there is no
more than three lines that come out of
her mouth yeah that was the most
surprising part because she is uh she
was the only thing I've seen her in is
30 Rock and and I thought she was
incredible in that and but everyone else
like to me when you put Adam Sandler in
a comedy movie it's great to have
surround him by other like if he's going
to do the whole like he's he's just kind
of enjoying himself on camera cuz
whether he's rich or poor he's going to
be the guy in a t-shirt and shorts you
know doesn't matter he's always going to
be like the laid-back guy and to put him
in here surrounded by a movie that has a
good production budget that has uh
attention to detail in the visuals that
has an ensemble around him that's really
putting in a a concerted effort with the
like Josh gad's really playing a
character even Kevin James is like doing
a hybrid of you know Kevin James and
playing the president you know he's
actually putting in an effort to play a
character and Peter Dinklage of course
and even Michelle Monahan I think this
is when Adam Sandler is utilized best uh
when we just want him to be the
relatable Adam Sandler that we all love
to hang out with and I thought the rest
like I like Kevin I liked everyone here
and Josh Gad can be kind of Hit or Miss
for me and I I actually like them a lot
too that's what I was going to say Josh
cat is in this the Sci-Fi thing that
used to be on Apple TV like it came out
two years ago I don't even know the name
of it I watched a few epod I've never
seen it no it's maybe it wasn't on Apple
it was like it's a you guys know it
they're in space and stuff goes down
they keep them on that spaceship listen
Josh Gad was in it talking about and I
was like I don't like Josh Gad this I it
got me off of him because I don't
remember him from a lot of films or TV
shows before I just was like oh yeah
that's Josh Gad and oh crap he's the
voice of Olaf and I was like he's fine
but I I didn't really like him and in
this movie I'm like oh I get the Josh
Gad thing now meaning if I had seen this
first I'd be like I understand why he is
a huge fan base yeah because he is very
funny and I really liked him in this
movie he was this is that kind of clich
that the mom's basement nerd character
is has been done to death yeah but you
know implementing it with a conspiracy
theorist and I thought he I thought he
actually did I'm trying to put my finger
on it of what he did different than what
you normally see like yeah he still got
that disheveled look but it's not
extreme in the way it is he seem he
actually seems smart and competent he's
not playing it like Kookie there's
actually like a Dr about it yeah I think
it feels just more grounded in like
internally who he is but kind of like uh
kind of like sometimes when you see Jack
Black and you're like there there's
sometimes when he's like more ground and
still Jack Black but then other times
you're like he's going full on like 120%
Jack Black it's that vibe
I like I like it when he plays a little
closer to home I like that with most
actors but um yeah that's that is what
it felt like in this movie possibly for
him because I believe what you're saying
is the Sci-Fi thing I'm thinking of I
still can't remember the name he he does
play I think like a zany kind of
character and I yeah just it didn't work
for me that show kind of didn't work I
wasn't very excited by it but I watched
a few you can't even remember the name
of it the I can't
good musical choices I like what I liked
about it have you seen the Goosebumps
movie with Jack Black
no okay so it's kind of similar and plot
sort of okay in the sense of all these
Goosebumps characters are coming a life
and then they have to like outrun and
survive and figure out how to put them
back in the books oh cool it's a neat
plot now my one of my main complaints
about that movie is whenever a a
character from Goose Goose mums came up
it was kind of the same bit all the time
character shows up and they got to run
away from it and that's pretty much it
character shows up and they got run away
from and what I thought was neat about
this is sure I mean it gets to a point
where it's just like a bombastic
cacophony of just shoot the thing like
sure but I still think there was enough
where they made an actual choice to
Let's create a level out of it you know
yeah like actually play it cuz they're
not really running in the beginning a
little bit they're playing playing it
while yeah it's like a VR experience but
instead of VR it's you're actually it's
a threat you know so to have like the
totally what was the first one the cic C
what was that one the centipede
centipede centipede uh the centipede one
like even with that it was more than
just shoot there was a strategy and the
pattern the whole thing right of course
Pac-Man um and then with and then like
Donkey Kong and and when yeah that one
was dope cuz that was a real set that we
partially they built and then also with
FFX and I'm like I think they had them
on um like a lift like when they put you
on a lift cuz I'm like there's no way
Michelle manam but there was one where
she's running on that thing and she
jumps over the barrel and I'm like it
seems like they had them on a lift so
they could do that and then they place
them back down you can keep running but
you just CGI the thing out and I feel
like they did that with the actual
people with the actual actors which and
I don't know but it that's maybe a
reason why it also looks super dope yeah
that's all likely yes um and then uh uh
the even like with the tetris one on the
building oh that was so smart even
though it's brief I'm like that's really
inventive of how of how they're doing
that I like how in comedy it starts off
where there's a lot of like uh my God
sorry no sleep there's a lot of uh a lot
of there like a wack like a slightly
wacky character and then there's a
straight man right there's a lot of that
kind of interaction and then as the
movie gets a little bit later you kind
of get um more wacky characters
interacting each other like I actually
really love the way that scene went down
with Josh Gad and the and the girl when
he first encounters her like how they
just commit to the genre of whatever
like weird fantasy this is at the time
yeah of how she she plays it subtle she
never speaks yeah and um I think that
actress is named Ashley Benson am I
wrong about that um but yeah I love how
she just never speaks and just the way
her she emotes there or and like even
Peter Dinklage was he wasn't that funny
at first no I wish I wish that he had
gotten to do it in his regular accent
cuz he would have been hilarious I feel
like he actually might have been funnier
if he did in his own accent way funnier
cuz like Peter is so funny and the
second he to opened up to start to talk
I was like this accent is not going to
work and his delivery and tone and
pacing is going to be totally thrown off
by it and I wish that they just would
have made the kid like from London but
he still lived around and because Peter
he's Prime Time funny what he just
didn't get a chance with the accent
there was like two or three moments
later on like in the finale I can't
remember what but I was like oh [__]
that was hilar I can't remember what he
there was some line he had that he
actually delivered I was like that oh
that he was like at least I'd get a nice
tasty Panini out that Pini line was
really well
delivered the Pini line was really funny
his reaction to
Martha yes yeah oh even when like Josh
Gad was like oh life and like his
reaction to that was really funny so
funny and even in the beginning in the
prison I was sort of listening to that
scene being so excited Peter dingl is in
it but then he starts talking I'm like I
don't like any of this the accent seems
way off and more I didn't like it but
anyway when he stopped talking and he
they were telling him about like you
can't have an island Camp these things
if you just look at Peter Peter he is
the best at quick subtle reactions that
are so funny like a flint of the eye
he'll just like do a thing with like his
eyes and you're like what that was it's
such a brilliant reaction that I just
want to see him on camera always yeah
and I you know I I got to give it up for
I this is the kind of movie where I
don't feel like people will would talk
about Michelle Monahan and not that she
is the star performer of this right but
she really kept up with the rest of the
cast very well and they gave her a role
that was different than than again like
most of these unless you're Drew Barry
more than most of these like Adam s
movies and um and I liked how she was
able to play a character that at first
just seems like divorce wife and then
you find out she's actually this high
ranking official in the government and
she she pulls off the the whole layers
of the character well and she had some
there was like a couple of pretty funny
like she that line about the Donkey Kong
thing like the editing and the way she
delivered it uh uh was it was so genuine
it was so genuine and that's what made
it hilarious yeah I was I was really
surprised by how much they actually used
her and I thought having them as like a
heart of the of the dynamic of of like
the the Romantic every one of these Adam
s movies has a romantic angle but but I
thought like that actually worked really
well here yeah and didn't feel like just
a thing they had to do like cuz I like
how came in they needed her to be in
that to help the the story progress
which is what we all want of like not
just in there because like Jane Jane is
just in there to be a wife to the
president she is not needed as a
character I mean maybe they just like he
needs a wife but like uh in regards to
the script in like story building in the
way we needed Michelle Monahan's like
character and they did utilize her in it
with good intent cuz I think what most
movies would have done is after he's
already like with the military Adam
Sandler then he meets her and then and
it's like here we go Force romance but
to actually have them Bond prior in a
completely separate and then get into
their their spat beforehand and then I
was like okay this works much smarter
as opposed to what the most movies will
do yeah I agree yeah and it gives us the
build up of also with the sun and how
video game Heavy he is like he's a nerd
and an adult and very you know thrown
into that video game thing but then it
proves to be useful all right so before
we end this off I want to show you what
Chris columus has directed cuz he's
directed a lot and I'm sure let me see
where's where's okay he's PR going so
fast I'm I'm on the producer credit
speed what's going on here here we go
he's directed a lot and for someon I can
call the adventures and babysitting oh
my God that that was one of my favorite
home alone2 Home Alone movies Mrs daire
9 months so good he did direct the first
two Harry Potter movies yeah uh rent ooh
Percy Jackson i' I've been wanting to
react to Percy Jackson I thought we we
going to do it let's do it you you I
haven't seen any of them I haven't seen
the Percy Jacks movies Christmas
Chronicles part two I don't think I've
seen so I might have to watch that cuz
he has directed some very good films
that I love that's insane yeah and he
like a high prolific producer as well oh
he produces a lot huh yeah he's produced
a [__] ton of
movies um yeah he's a big ass producer
but yeah man I I I really I've got I'm
not going to lie I enjoyed the hell out
of that film I I am good times I was
reluctantly step I was just like let's
just choose one of the comedies cuz I
just but that surprisingly uh that that
brought me a lot of Joy I had a really
great time with that it makes me want to
say Chris Columbus this is my this is my
note to you I'm an actor put me in your
stuff do it because your stuff is great
and I am just realizing how much great
stuff you've directed you won't ever
watch this or hear this but I'm saying
there's might be people that are like
hey man I know Chris Chris is my best
friend and then you're like yo Chris
Tara Ericson right and then you're like
get get on it get with it get with it
put me to work in as an actor do it yeah
don't anyway okay that's it that's I you
have another movie to shoot with Aaron I
do and I'm pretty sure he's outside he's
outside right now probably end the video
we have to go yeah we love you so much
leave a like leave a comment tell us how
cool we are and ring the bell and we
love you so much by all the t-shirts
become a patreon okay
bye all right guys since we have uh only
a few days left in the month we have to
make sure that we are getting everyone
taken care of for our super sexies who
get a patron of the day shout out so
we're going to have to do two shout outs
in this video and uh so what two people
do we know John just named I actually
got a perfect two I think would go
really nicely together who and that's
Maria Hammond okay and fev Doran
fascinating because they're both get
this they're both different you know
walks of life different kinds of people
however both uh bring this generous
enthusiastic spirit and I feel like if
Maria was to adopt fev they could create
like the most perfect wholesome you know
uh uh uh the kind of family unit you
would want to move into your
neighborhood because you know they would
be taken care of of you you know they
would be bringing you gifts and things
they would be cooking for you but they
would also be sharing in your interests
you know what I mean they're two you
know uh enthusiastic passionate people
but who also seem to really want to care
for the people around them you know what
I mean and I'm grateful for those vibes
wow you know I was I I I thought we
would just do a one at a time and just
say what we're grateful for about them
and then you turned this into some crazy
amalgamation about adoption and let's do
your version now I don't know if we we
could I think we got a roll with this
one I got a yes and it but I wanted to
interrupt with my no but briefly yes
before going into the yes and here um
yeah I like I like where your head's at
than Maria's a very tender woman yes
with a and she loves to spoil those that
are her children or on she considers to
be like her children yeah and L is great
at expressing his gratitude for those
things so childlike wonder I think that
the two of them together if they were
mother and son there would just be a
constant it would be kind of annoying
the amount of appreciation they would
just keep dishing back and forth to each
other I they're also both very
passionate so I could see it getting
like really heated and it's all flowers
until they find that one thing they
disagree on yeah they disagree on it
then it just gets like oh ugly business
and they probably don't talk to each
other for like 6 day business days and
then eventually eventually they would
come back around again and realize we
need to put our petty squabbles to the
side and know what we mad about yeah and
then eventually they would remember and
then ccle continue of
gratitude vitriol just doesn't stop gra
a vitrio well damn dude um I mean I love
you both uh one gives us more than the
other uh in terms of physical tangible
gifts we can actually hold on camera and
put on the set yes so you know there's
that meaning fed if you want more
gratitude from us yeah spend more of
your hard-earned
dollars cuz that's the key to my heart
that's my love language gifts yes um I
don't I don't like the other love
language I think they'll waste of
everyone's time going to replace all the
the links on the Channel Bio description
with just your wish list
please please get more of those Nifty
cabinets over there please man got some
new cabinets in the studio was so
excited no it's not about that FL you
give what you can which is not enough no
you give what you can you got to always
have something to strive for you know
what I mean you know you always you've
always been extremely generous with us
via your patreon dollars but also with
your time and your energy your thoughts
you contribute to like every single live
stream that we do and Maria before you
know it I'm I'm expecting to hear some
loud tow truck outside called what is
being hauled and then I'm going to hear
like oh damn she's just dropped off a
cruise ship right into our
driveway cuz that's the kind that's
that's the I mean let's face it after
everything you've given us Maria that's
just the next step is a cruise ship a
giant boing vessel a giant boat just
right outside our door can you imagine
how cool a reject Nation yacht could be
I know and we react live on the yacht
yeah the camera would never stay
still oh yeah it' be very nausey in cuz
will be still but the background will
always be moving yeah cick reaction but
all jokes aside uh you both are
incredibly generous and both
heartwarming souls in every regard it's
a good pair John good job thanks would
make it weird you made it weird you all
right talk to you soon thanks for being
here
[Music]